hello and welcome to a brief clip from
this week's game spot of Thrones if
you'd like to watch the full video head
over to youtube.com slash game spot bran
can't control his green seeing I think
also I love the fact that this episode
was directed by Jack bender who did a
bunch of episodes of Lost
so when bran was having that crazy
vision thing I was like oh this is so
series four of loss we have to go back
we have to go back and back he did go so
Dave you've been through
Bran's vision it was a lot of chopping
and changing but you've seen some quite
interesting things they do
flash flash back quite sporadically but
there are some quite interesting moments
if you put them all in in order so most
interesting of all is that we it's the
first time we see the Mad King himself
he's just shouting burn them all you see
shots of wildfire which is played a big
part in the series in the past mmm very
bright green yeah it's pretty obviously
wildfire yeah just big green flames
murdering loads of dudes then we see
shots of King's Landing in smoke so not
sure if that's like before forward or
after yeah or in like money burn the
rebels yeah and then we see Jaime take
his famous action of stabbing him in the
back and then takes the seat of throne
for himself mmm maybe just because he's
tired because he's no king yeah well arm
is heavy yeah he's just like oh man this
seat although he did you an old dude
yeah don't think it was that difficult
he also gets to witness the death of his
brother his father and his mother he
wasn't any of those no no he was way way
away yeah so he knows they're all dead
but he's this is the first time he's
like obviously seen it lots of shots of
the night King as well hmm at the head
of his army at hardhome
no they took over all the white the
wildlings yeah when he raises the dead
they're all staring off as they the few
flee across the lake touching the face
of the the baby that we saw a long time
ago and turning it you see his eyes turn
turned blue
I do wonder about that baby though I
feel like it's gonna have some it's
gonna come back yeah at some point
they're reminding us for a reason
yeah scores of the undead the moment he
touched brands arm and kind of ruined
their little underground tree den that
they all had it's like you know when you
do something embarrassing and at night
you're sat there going did that I can't
believe I did that that is essentially
what our brands vision was like I
remember time I just destroyed Westeros
because I was an idiot
doomed a species to extinction and then
we even see the fight that the night
king had with brands brother John
obviously another no way he has any
knowledge of that shots of Danny with
the Dragons as well his own fall from
the tower and what appears to be young
Ned's hand covered in blood so plus Jake
well there's the shots of wildfire the
Mad King shouting the White Walkers do
we think this confirms another theory
we're talking about where brands
whispers into the past are affecting way
more than we thought yeah good yeah it
looks like that's what they're leaning
towards I mean the Mad King Aerys thing
burned them all is obviously the thing
that people really focus on was you know
was that brand kind of whispering in his
ear telling him to burn the White
Walkers or and he's missing two rebels I
think the opposite equals J thing is
like if you look closer at that shot
there's clearly like I think if we go
back and watch the scene at the Tower of
joy you could probably make out that
that is definitely Ned Stark
yes bracer yeah and there looks like a
woman's hand underneath but it looks
like the babies have been cut out like
that's is that a I mean cesarean section
possibly yeah yeah but like why was it a
difficult birth was it someone knew the
real parentage of the baby poison get
the kid out yeah mother can die that's
all we know right like he went to tower
of joy and there was blood and promise
me Ned and there are a lot of shots in
this do you think many more are kind of
hinting a future plot lines like the
night King's March or even Lady Stone
Huck's we do see all Catelyn get her
throat cut now that could have just been
for context and these are the family
dying or it could be hinting at
something I think because later on the
episode when they go to the twins they
make a real big deal about wall
rivers who is the one who actually cut
the throat and I feel like this is all
sort of just reminding everyone of what
happened like why the Tully's want
revenge why the Starks want revenge and
also maybe seeding ladies no not because
it definitely feels like a lot of the
flashbacks off and a lot of the
references that have been made are kind
of just playing everyone towards
reminding you about Catelyn Stark so
that when she comes back people are like
going like what the hell's this all
about yeah it definitely feels like
setup for that but like you said before
it's it's implied that it's the
Brotherhood of that banners that raised
her and we've mentioned before that the
Brotherhood without banners are raiding
the supply lines mmm for the Walters
that are assaulting Riverrun and we are
like we see the scene where he says show
them the knife that cut Catelyn Stark's
throat who's currently leading the
Brotherhood of banners
it'll be beric Dondarrion because they
have soros of my but depending on
whether or not Lady Stoneheart back she
actually does take control of the
Brotherhood so she if she's been brought
back she's the one leading them getting
revenge on the phrase if she's not then
it's beric Dondarrion and they have some
history with people returning from the
dead and that kind of stuff right yeah
yeah Barrack has been seven times so and
after all the time-travel stuff the
raising the dead stuff the half white
Walker cold hand stuff I always thought
that bringing back Lady Stoneheart for
the dead would be like oh that's a bit
too far-fetched it's like the least
far-fetched yeah no it happened now it's
fine
you